All right, here's the question:
does modern-day Georgetown
University have a responsibility
to take care of the descendants
of the slaves
whose sale essentially
saved it from going under?
A lot of thorny issues here,
so let's talk to our resident
black egghead, Felonious Monk.
(cheering, applause)
-Felonious, welcome to the show.
-Thanks. Thanks.
All right.
I want to try to talk this out,
Felonious, so...
should Georgetown do something
for the great-great-great-
grandchildren of these slaves?
Well, Brother Larry, when one--
be it institution
or singular corporus--
partake in the odious
reprobation that is tenancy
over another's very anima,
an ovule is sown in Gaia's
breast that burgeons not only
in the immediate, but for
an unknowable epoch thereafter.
Right, right, right, right.
Right, okay, so you're saying
we're still feeling
slavery's effects today.
Be you a parrot?
That is what I just said.
Oh, I know, totally.
I'm just clearing it up
for the audience, man, you know.
They might have...
I get it, I get it. Okay.
But, okay, but what about
the fact that The New York Times
says, uh, Georgetown
should set up scholarships
for the descendants
of all these slaves?
Well, if Georgetown's
halls of academe found salvation
in the traffickment of their
fellows in the brotherhood
of man, then there be
a blot upon
each certificate
endowed therein.
And until amendment is made,
no esteem can be lent
to its conferment.
Okay, okay. So...
Oh, so you're saying
some form of repar...
-Ah, ah, ah.
-Uh...
That vocable remains
unuttered in our colloquy.
Right, colloquy.
Uh, sorry about that.
My bad.
Uh, but-but, I mean,
still, this seems like
a clear-cut case where repara...
And yet...
you recapitulate with that word.
Your unceasing constancy
would be risible
if it weren't so temerarious.
I'm just trying to say
"reparations."
One must be disposed
for ferment and tumult
when the notion finds itself
conjected aloud.
Wait, you just don't
want me to say "reparations"
because it
freaks people out, right?
I plaintively beg
that you preclude
further use of the R word,
Brother Larry.
WILMORE:
Sorry, sorry.
When one invokes compulsory
fiduciary redress
using that appellation,
the anglo-hominidae
feels awakened
within the primal,
ominous presentiment.
Are you saying
white people get scared?
Yo...
Yo, white people
flip the (bleep) out
if you say "reparations".
-(cheering, applause)
-Uh... Uh... Uh, Broth...
Hey. Now I... I understand
that. I understand that.
Okay. Okay, so, all right,
so, if we're not calling them
"reparations," then what?
What do we...
Uh... I propose
an idiom of equal meaning
possessing of less enmity
in its associations.
Something akin to...
"compaymensement."
Yes, Georgetown should pay
a hefty compaymensement
to every descendant it can.
Compaymense... Wh-Wh... But why
don't we just say "reparations"?
You just made up
a fancy-sounding word
to distract from what
you're actually saying.
Uh, yeah, Larry.
That's kind of my whole deal.
Right. Felonious Munk, everyone!